welcome back to new rock stars i'm
whitney van laningham and oh my god new
dimension just dropped in episode three
of ms marvel we meet a brand new team of
interstellar baddies the gin or the
clandestine extraterrestrials who are
banished to earth and have spent the
last hundred years trying to get back
home but getting home requires the use
of the bangle they found while tomb
raiding and that super powered piece of
jewelry just so happens to be in the
hands of a 16 year old avengers fan girl
today i'm going to break down everything
we know about the gin clandestines and
their afterlife the nor we meet this
group in british occupied india in 1942
just as they've found a magical item
that they believe will help them return
to their home planet their cruise made
up of aisha kamala's great-grandmother
najma the leader and future mother of
komron faria salim and adam najma and
the others have super strength arya can
summon a spear to use in battle saleem
has a weaponized belt turned whip called
an urumi and autumn wields a mace we
haven't yet gotten a clean look at
najma's weapon but it appears to be a
double-bladed throwing weapon shaped
like a lightning bolt they find the
bangle still attached to a severed cree
arm which tells me that it might be an
ancient type of pre-tech but we'll come
back to that later although the bracelet
is missing its twin and farya voices her
concern that there's a whole ass dead
body part attached to it they decide to
risk it anyways because they have no
other options this bengal is their only
hope of returning to their home
dimension when the cave collapses the
team is separated and aisha disappears
along with the bengal najima explains to
kamala that her great-grandmother along
with the rest of the clandestine are not
exactly from around these parts their
party didn't arrive on earth by choice
they were forced out of their own
dimension and doomed to live in ours she
also reveals to kamala they are beings
from the nord dimension the word nor
meaning divine light in arabic this
appears to be the afterlife esque place
we saw filled with all of those glowing
figures in the first episode its purple
hue is reminiscent of the lavender glow
of both the ancestral plains and the dua
but their main difference is that the
nor like the astral plane also houses
living beings like this party najma and
the others aren't able to access the
noir's true potential from our dimension
but she believes that because of
kamala's connection to earth she may be
the key to unlocking their gateway home
according to najma this group of
supernatural beings goes by a lot of
names ajanabi which means strange alien
or foreign majnun which roughly
translates to crazy person unseen or the
clandestine but they're most commonly
known as jinn the folklore of jinn was
passed down from pre-islamic mythology
and were referred to as genies as the
anglo-saxon world learned of these
creatures like humans gin can either be
good or evil so some people also call
them demons depending on the being's
personal vibe in irl mythology they're
also invisible to the human eye and age
at a much slower rate than us normies do
later when kamala's dad reads bruno's
gin research out loud we learned that in
the mcu there's also an additional
legend that a group of jinn were exiled
here from their home damned to live out
the rest of their long miserable days on
this planet and according to him jin
move in the shadows searching for an
artifact that will take them home in the
comics depictions of gin are sporadic
inconsistent and rarely culturally
sensitive one of the notable groups of
gin was the obscure family of the
clandestine in 1994 alan davis first
introduced the clandestine in marvel
comics presents number 158. this
clandestine was two words as in the
family clan of destine this comic run
introduced a man named adam dustin who
was visited in a dream by a jinn named
elala believing her to be an angel adam
released her from captivity with the new
power she granted him and the two fell
in love allah turned adam into an
immortal man and the two had half gin
half human children who together formed
the clandestine the family death stein
used their powers primarily for selfish
gain in the comics spreading their
lineage across the world some of these
branches became super villains while
others ended up working alongside
various marvel heroes as time moved
through the modern age this run gave us
a look at the way superhumans alter
their powers and allegiances over the
centuries adapting as the years went on
in the mcu however the clandestine one
word not two that we meet in ms marvel
are fully gin but like their comic book
predecessors they still clearly use
their powers for their own selfish
motivations although they pretend to be
on kamala's side in the beginning
offering her their guidance and
protection najima flips on a dime when
komron confesses that it might be too
dangerous for kamala to send them home
via interdimensional bangle he tells
kamala that his mom will stop at
absolutely nothing to get her way and
that like the other gin will kill every
single person at the wedding on site
side quest did anyone else think that it
was kind of bonkers that they've been
waiting over a hundred years to find
this thing and the second kamala
hesitates they want her blood like calm
down dudes you've waited this long have
a little patience she probably would
have helped you if you just gave her
some time like even a single day after
the fight najima grabs kamala's wrist
clasping the bangle in her palm the two
of them experience a vision of a
locomotive barreling towards them from
the nora dimension the train has the
word karachi emblazoned on the front
karachi is the largest city in pakistan
and apparently where kamala's grandma
nani lives after the gin are subdued and
taken into custody by the dodc nani
facetimes kamala back in her bedroom at
home she urges her granddaughter to come
to karachi immediately and to bring her
mother along as well nani reveals that
she also saw the train in a norovision
confirming the women in their family all
likely possess the talents imbued in
them by their ancestors so that's
everything we currently know about the
gin at least according to the comics in
the first few episodes of miss marvel
but now it's time to theorize why were
the clandestine exiled from the newer
given the team's incredibly violent
tendencies i bet my britch is that they
were villains in their home dimension
too but if that's the case it would also
mean that aisha did something banishment
worthy i definitely don't want to make
any rash assumptions that kamala's
great-grandma was a super villain
because i respect the elderly but i
don't know maybe these guys got kicked
out because they were being [ __ ] my
question is what exactly did they do
that's where the cree technology used to
create the bengal might come in this is
definitely speculation and i could be
totally wrong but hear me out what if
these gin were involved somehow in the
kree skrull war it would explain how
they knew to look for the bengals and if
they committed any war crimes during
these space battles that could
constitute grounds for banishment from
the noir comic book kamala was also a
descendant of pre-war instruments by way
of her inhuman heritage so this might be
how the mcu retains her connection to
the cree without making her go through
pterogenesis i'll admit that it's kind
of a wild theory but there are other
ways that kevin feige could ultimately
connect the gin and the cree especially
with the noir dimension in play could
the cree also have access to the noir
could the technology that they've built
including this bangle be pulling from
this dimension in the same way that moon
knight drew his powers from khanshu in
the duat and black panther drew his
strength from his father and the
ancestral plains are the figures we saw
in the nor somehow providing magic for
those connected to their realm eric
speculated in his video that this bangle
could be ancient cree technology from a
group that arrived on earth possibly
around the same time the vibranium
meteorite crashed in wakanda perhaps
like the ten rings the cree also brought
these bangles to our planet long ago and
now that we've learned the rules of the
many many mcu afterlives i'm interested
to know why exactly kamala her family
and her gin relatives picture the noir
as blinding purple light actually eric
did a whole video summarizing everything
we know about these dead worlds that you
should check out in full but to
summarize a bit of what he already told
you is after lives typically appear to
those that experience them as whatever
the person's earthly beliefs customs or
even fears were in life steven grant and
mark spector find themselves in a psych
ward thanos sees the archway where he
first met gamora the ancient one
ventured to the astral plane and odin's
soul went to valhalla when he died
because of this inherent trait in all
mcu afterlife and afterlife adjacent
dimensions it's understandable that
kamala hernani and najma all saw that
train right beforehand najma accused
kamala betraying her so my theory is
that this train is attached to some sort
of fear trauma or past regret possibly
stemming from aisha's abandonment not
only did she disappear from her gin
buddies with the bangle in toe she isn't
kamala's family's favorite member aisha
is seldom spoken of and it's clear that
kamala's mom doesn't talk about her at
all are they collectively picturing this
train in the nor due to aisha's
perceived betrayal could aisha have been
killed by this train for refusing to
turn over the bengals subsequently
seemingly abandoning her family without
warning i don't have an answer for
exactly what or who these glowing
figures are however eric has speculated
that they look like the outlines of
watchers but they could also be gin
spirits in their home world there might
even be a few cree souls in there who
knows but like i said a second ago i do
think that the bengal could be drawing
its powers from these beings whatever
they are and if kamala really does have
a stronger connection to the realm
either because of her human status or
due to the clandestine's banishment will
hopefully get to learn their true
identities by the end of the season
follow me on instagram and twitter
whitneypuppy follow new rockstars
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you